-Here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
describe it to your opponent.
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
Blake, why don't you
pick the first...box?
-I feel like I'm on
"The Price is Right."
That was so exciting.
Okay, I take it first?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright. Already,
it looks pretty light.
Could have pretended
it was heavy,
but you didn't. Yeah.
Well, alright.
♪♪
-Oh, Lord, have mercy.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
What I have in my hands here --
-Yeah. What do you have
in your hands there?
-It's milky.
There's some soggy,
rainbow-y chunks in here.
It's a milky, soggy,
rainbow-y, chunky --
-This is how
you describe something?
This is how you describe
something real
that's in front of you?
-Time-telling device.
-Oh? Time-telling device?
-Mm-hmm.
-Now, that would only mean one
thing to me, a watch, perhaps?
-Mm-hmm.
-What else could tell time,
a sundial?
-Mm-hmm, yeah, a sundial.
What are you, like,
an ancient Greek?
-Yeah, well, a time-telling
device? Who says that?
I think that you're lying.
I do not believe
that that is what you have.
You are -- That is a lie.
-Do I win if you got it right,
or do I win if --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-To be honest -- To be honest,
I just forgot for a second.
[ Laughter ]
You -- No, if I get it right,
you lose.
-Then I was lying?
-Yes.
-Oh, I want to take it back.
-No!
-Wait.
-Wait, what?
Oh, wait.
You did win.
Oh, my gosh. You won.
That was --
[ Dinging ]
Oh. No, I saw
what you did there.
That was a very odd description,
a very odd description.
-The weirdest game
I've ever played.
-She did have that.
You're right. It's an odd game.
-Who makes these things up?
-Dude, we --
Alright. Alright.
[ Audience shouting
indistinctly ]
Someone just screamed, "3! 3!"
She's yelling "3." Alright.
Here we go. Here we go. Alright.
-Oh, God.
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Gasping ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I'd say it's --
It's funny.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's funny.
It's funny that you're here.
-Mm-hmm.
-'Cause it's a paperweight.
[ Laughter ]
It's got a head on it.
It's like a very weighted,
weight.
Brass, I'd say,
a mixture of metals.
-Mm-hmm.
-In the brass variety.
-Unlacquered brass or --
-Yeah, it's a matte.
-A matte brass?
-Two T's and an E, matte finish.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, there's
a Deadpool head on top.
[ Laughter ]
-Describe the shape of the head.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Cylinder --
Cylinder --
Like a cylinder head.
-Like, with the mask
or without the mask?
-Oh, with the mask.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, mask head.
-And, like, describe
the back of the head.
-It's red and black?
-You're lying.
-What?
-Yeah.
He's got a little, "Vloop!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wait, is that The Rock?
-Yes, it's The Rock.
-Is that The Rock --
-The Rock on a rock.
-Wait, you've got
to give that to me.
My husband's working
with him right now.
This will be his, like,
really creepy star gift.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to give it to him
and tell him that Ryan
hand-painted it for him.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
I'm so mad you got that.
Alright.
-Oh wait, I have to put it
back in the box, right?
-Let's do one more.
Yeah, I can take it.
Here, I'll give this to my wife.
[ Laughter ]
She loves "The Wizard of Oz."
Here you go.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, whoa! I just activated
the cereal. Okay.
We have -- Someone has to eat
this before the time's up.
-Oh, wait, that's so fun.
-Alright, we'll do
one more last one.
-Wait.
[ Audience shouting
indistinctly ]
Whew, this is so light.
Whoa, it's the helium
in this thing.
-Oh, I just heard it.
It was very heavy.
You lied already.
Whew!
-Okay.
♪♪
Oh, that's real!
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if you're going to
get this pop culture reference.
[ Laughter ]
I think that's Devon Sawa.
Um...
-Oh. Oh, is it?
[ Laughter ]
Then I probably know
exactly what it is.
-It's "J-14."
-"J-14."
-Mm-hmm, with a --
Oh, God.
It's like a trough of --
-I don't --
-No, like a pedestal,
like, what do you --
Like a bird bath, I guess,
of actual chili.
-Alright. Those are the first
two things I understood
that you said. Alright.
Bird bath and chili, alright.
Now, we're on my level.
-Devon Sawa, I told you.
You don't remember Devon Sawa?
-Devon Sawa is my best roommate.
-He was like a teen dream.
-He was my favorite. What?
-I mean, I think
it's Devon Sawa.
Maybe I'm the old one.
I don't know.
Okay, and then there's, like,
a bird bath of fresh chili
with freshly grated cheese
and chives and sour cream,
and then there's a bird.
-Stop. Stop talking. Stop.
-There's a bird...
-Stop! Stop talking!
-...with green juice.
-Stop talking!
Stop it right now!
-With a Mohawk.
-'Cause let me
tell you something!
I would have smelled chili,
if chili was out of that box.
So -- I'm a detective.
Blake Lively, you lie!
-Well, let me start
with the chili first.
[ Laughter ]
-What? Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What? I didn't win.
-Yes, because it was chili --
-Oh, 'cause I did lie.
Yeah, I did lie.
-I have no idea.
Blake Lively, everyone,
is the win--
[ Cheers and applause ]